- All right, y'all.
(audience cheering)
We have time for one more story
on this Martin Luther King Jr. Day,
and it's a really important one.
This is What I'm Liking.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
It's easy to think the life and legacy
of Martin Luther King
Jr. are the distant past,
but that's not the case.
Today marks what would've
been his 94th birthday
and his work continues to this day.
To emphasize that point,
his only grandchild is still a teenager.
She's also an activist
and author, just like her grandfather.
Her latest children's book
is, "We Dream a World".
Here to talk about it,
is Yolanda Renee King.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Hello!
- Hi!
- Welcome to the show and
congratulations on this.
This is such a cool achievement.
- Thank you so much and
thank you for having me.
- Absolutely, so tell us about the book.
- So the book is...
Well it's a children's book,
and it's inspired
by the late Langston Hughes'
poem, "We Dream a World",
which actually, interestingly enough,
inspired the "I Have a Dream" speech.
And it really shows, using imagery
and poetic language, the type of world
that we can have and the type of world
that I think we talk about so much,
but we forget what that looks like.
And so, I think that this
book will really give kids
and really honestly, families,
a visual of the type of world
that we can have.
- Absolutely, we always
need reminders, right?
Absolutely.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So how do you plan
to honor your grandfather's legacy today?
- So our organization,
my family's organization,
the Drum Major Institute,
we're actually working
on launching our service initiative today.
Because five years from
now, for the 100th birthday,
we are trying to obtain 100 million hours
of service across the nation.
So today is the launch of
our new service initiative.
- That's incredible!
(audience applauding)
Well, Yolanda's latest book,
"We Dream a World", is available right now
and everyone is going home with a copy!
You're all getting one.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much, Yolanda.
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
support the ongoing work of your family.
So they're gonna be writing
the Drum Major Institute
a check for $1000 just to help out.
How does that sound?
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Yolanda!
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Cynthia Erivo, Amel Amin,
Coleman Woodson Jr. and Kings Return.
Have a good day, y'all,
and if it's not, try and change it.